il ya un truc qui cartonne en ce moment
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est le thème
yard challenge ça veut dire que vous
mettez une photo de vous il ya dix ans
et vous mettez une photo de vous
maintenant on l'a fait avec tous les
chroniqueurs vous allez voir et c'est
incroyable les tout petits que vous
aviez alors on l'a fait pour gardons
gars on regardera au gardien il ya dix
ans maintenant franchement mais en
direct a rajeuni frère c'est laquelle il
ya dix ans et c'est là qu'elle ouais
c'est vrai il ya dix ans tessa là je te
jure je trouve merci mais non mais c'est
offensant ufr ont déjà fait une appli
sur quatre et un parc ou non mais je te
jure mais la tête et frère tu étais
graff attila tas d'effets coin et ouais
mais j'ai labouré quand même surtout
aller way et la bomba très bien plus
sobre de pour la fée pour sur pierre
mocky aussi des champions vous avez quel
âge 85 85 ans il magnifie franchement
l'avenir 4 bat jean pierre c'est pas ou
fait non plus non mais c'est vrai qu'à
pas songé jean-pierre franchement t'as
vu ta pas changé un peu comme un
benjamin castaldi lui il était resté à
50 ans tu rigoles et mes frères
non franchement c'est pas en fait tu
étais passeport était plus jeune
ouais ouais c'est vrai était plus jeune
les voilà valérie bénaïm
la [ __ ] mal à changer de huawei m&p
naim là on dirait au livre la femme de
popeye mais où il connaît un canada
avant benhaim sans rigoler on dirait la
première de la classe et genre il ya les
premières de la sympathique elle ratera
celle à travers de la casse qui lui le
classeur ben j'en ai rien à [ __ ] avec
apprendre qu elles sont ça n'est pas
normal prenez une gomme mal à l'afp si
ça t'intéresse pas qu'il est plaisant
c'est vrai avoue alors vous abbas à se
voir oui vous alors vous vous je ne sais
pas je n'ai pas vu la photo mais je vous
trouve en tout cas de plus en plus pour
enlever votre perruque pour qu'on vous
voit bien là j'aurais pu dire je n'ai
pas trouvé de photos mais j'ai joué je
regardais malheureusement il métisse
cent fois mieux maintenant j'étais chou
époque
maintenant vous êtes beaucoup plus
grande qu'avant assure non et ils sont
soit plus là les cheveux restent des
cheveux des frères là on dirait que tvo
qui veulent partir on dirait que c'est
beau je suis normal je sais ce que c'est
aux dires elle présente un patron si
géraldine maillet oui c'est moi
géraldine maillet merci géraldine
holloway web pour pop aux propos il y en
a beaucoup qui aimerait être le stylo
là c'est vrai que là on aura envie
d'être la plus avoir de vie ont choisi
les photos
bien sûr il ya la queue jeudi photo
adore vous bougez j'espère que l'année
prochaine vous ne choisiraient pas à
travailler au hasard merci gilles alors
j d il a toujours été au top on va
regarder regardé l'avant après de gilles
regarder huawei m et gilles tu es passé
mais tu travailles tu t'habilles et
jones a highway est là et là maintenant
c'est un autre décès pareil non mais
c'est pas ça m'aurait bien le plus bas
mais maintenant ils vont plupart sont
mis à six si tu as regardé leur tournée
vous met la main aux tonnes contre le
vent tourner et vous voilà merci label
regardez regardez isabelle alors
isabelle on appris à 100 en rigole sava
ina voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors j'ai pas on m'a fait chier pendant
deux heures pour shutter une photo
correcte
yb le mans et vous passiez on lit à la
photos d'isa sinon on l'a au oui
franchement bah je vais dire tu es tu as
ta pas trop changer non pas parce que je
veux quand même si on a pris beaucoup de
retard dans la vie mais là j'ai pris un
sacré coup de pelle non je suis pas
d'accord pas d'accord
merci en tout cas c'est une base c'est
une blague qui cartonne chez jardiland
merci on va passer à delphine modèle
final année ouais bah ouais bah c'est
pas ces mêmes délires quoi c'est
l'adolescente en alsace et nyon ouais
pas ça ne fait millions ouais saviez cas
là je voudrais ya disons saison 17
merci c'est d'accord très bien roger est
déjà cinq en plus
[Rires]
l'amour qu'on embrasse croyais qu'on
envoie je suis qui nous regarde et je
sais qu'il va bientôt manger on avait
compris fallait pas ça tombe problème
calme-toi calme-toi calme toi alors
votre maire s'il faut savoir s'arrêter
francesca francesca regarder alors il ya
dix ans c'est quoi ta faisait la star ac
non c'était bien après le live texte il
ya 15 ans merci et me papa comme ça
jusqu'à mathieu de leur égard raymond
rey montréal et ouais bon c'est la même
personne là là là où il vient de
commettre un larcin
c'est clair
oui c'est sûr que ça fait là même où
même on va pas se battre
voilà la vie autour de la scène alors
moi j'ai les mains j'ai la même chaîne
soit dans l'émission de patrick sabatier
a atteint 2 m'avait regardé l'émission
d'avis que ces boîtiers et top ce soit
juste pour moi sur la tête de ma mère
j'ai à mes jeans chaîne mon frère je
dirais que c'est un essai bassens un
antivol bonjour voila j'ai cru qu'on
allait me voler alors qu'oliver novelli
qu'arriver novelli à eau
vous étiez prune la selle et sans
rigoler si ouf
ah ouais ben je vous préfère maintenant
mais on a bientôt se croient sur kelly
vely regardons à dos tous regardé quels
iv d'aurélie on me dit qu'on ad'autres
douce away canivez novelli là
normalement c'est là il ya le grand
frère qui vient chez les dames
[Applaudissements]
son contrat est le congrès à l'ecam à
acheter je peux pas laisser passer ça
tamer comment tu vois là ta mère de dieu
doit apprendre le respect avec toi tu
vas apprendre le respect nous reste avec
moi je le dis rien c'est une ado
difficiles et il y en a eu au dessus des
autres et reno tombé des nues la lette
au métropolis
elle avait signalé l'uia mais ça arrive
et vous savez dr albrand signaler ou la
mère de samantha fox et aura à wes
herrett sont là samantha fox sans le
renard est alors et papiers peints qui
baille à moi je crois mon frère non
c'est pas dégueulasse ce 6ème bien moi
vous aviez des problèmes de vue non mais
je voulais me voyais pas l'intérêt
je sortais de deux périodes difficiles à
ben haim donc voila merci aux deux cas
tiens ya le grand frère qui nous
regardent et qui nous dit qu'il veut
bien s'occuper de crédit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]